foreign
[Music]
way to the party here but what we lost
in time we will make up an effort
we lost in time we will make up in
efforts here we go
I'm literally off the plane off out of
the bed
out of the Dead
into the computer so please forgive my
please excuse my dear Aunt Sally as they
say
I feel like this guy should not have put
the VIN after his first four letters of
his name
sure I would have been enough
all right hmm oh my gosh
Good Start let's start I I mean she's
five he attacked the piece I didn't move
it
I'm literally doing only one thing in
this game and that is waiting for his
time to run out
hmm
okay losing to a 1700 in the first round
nice
at least I won with 41 seconds on the
clock
today 1800 I like this progression it's
like a little Fibonacci Sequence maybe
we'll play 1900 in the next round in the
2000.
and then by about 2025 we'll get to
2500.
another piece there but
it's been my I've been in the business
of doing that recently
whoa out there
let's get Knight F6 but I don't really
care about that
um
let's look like this
black is winning
it's Red Bull I mean I I'm literally I
don't know how I'm even upright right
now
okay how about a nice little 1900 okay
2500 now I have to play a little bit
better than I did the first two games
but not much better just a little bit
better
[Music]
the only time I have ever to drinks are
before below for all set as I have
discovered
where am I
okay this this must be your first time
in this in the Stream
I mean there's nothing I can do if I if
I stay in the same place I moved
if I move I moved like doesn't matter
where I am I'm always like why are
always a different location
[Music]
yeah white is winning but it's gonna
take some time for me to convert
what we're gonna do is go H4 and then
eventually G5 and create the passer on
the king side
and when
okay that was a nice game that was my
first nice game of the bulletpro
[Music]
now please resign
please please please please resign
[Music]
thank you
thank you Nick sake and crudery for the
prime
oh gosh we're playing God okay I have to
be careful
foreign
[Music]
trap actually
come on cut it you gotta know this stuff
come on gotta you gotta know that you've
got to know that trap
ski is Gonna Keep playing
Young Money after all that you've talked
about you're gonna play neridisky down a
pace in a bullet game royally girl
you've got 26 seconds my mind here in
the South we don't take Conley that kind
of behavior
you're gonna go kick something
[Music]
H5 I'm gonna open up some files
flag you like there's no tomorrow girl
foreign
the moves I'm making are insignificant
here
the only thing I have to do is not get
mated here that's the one the one way I
lose this game is I get mated somehow on
F3 I'm usually very good at figuring out
ways to do that but not this time
Cena or the young Argentinian phenom
thank you
for 77 is the move here
but how do I follow up or create is the
question
oh I had enough to be 70985 would be
real nice
[Music]
and now I'm just out of full Pawn
whoa
kid really
what if I go like this and then three
oh yes E4
oh man stuck
very good player
hopefully I can flag him here
he's finding all the best moves it
doesn't matter how much time he is
yeah
okay that was not a good move
he had Rook D2 also
that piece will help
um mate no mate
oh how do I step on though
like this
far
and they keep getting giving me white
and I keep playing terribly
no fascino's very good I mean he's these
kids are good
the H doesn't matter anymore they're
just good
I mean he played brilliant he literally
played a brilliant game in that game
just he's just slow
I got what am I doing
okay you can't I cannot lose to Ibarra I
don't like listen to him
but that you can get that that is
precisely what I'm doing
okay just go G3 and play calm
[Music]
why did I do that as a stupid move
trying to check Madame in the end game
here
okay obviously I'm gonna go for the win
I have a draw sort of in my pocket and
now I went yeah that's exactly what I
thought would happen
it might it might blend or something
like that
okay when I hand restrained that's dachi
Lin I think he's a good role player
oh my gosh okay thank God I played H6
it's not it's far from a disaster
nuclear war has not been started with
that with that mistake it's not pleasant
either
[Music]
I always forget what's that phrase they
use in Chernobyl
not great but not not good
ah I had Knight takes F2
[Music]
um
not great not terrible
the reasons are normal not great
[Music]
five you're back repeat once seven
um shoot like this
you know likey you know likey
oh
look at that move out
oh but he can't take
oh Rook B5 crap oh man I blunted a piece
and now we'll enter the game
[Music]
potentially
you know no I win somehow I I'm still
able to win I was like down a full piece
there
man oh okay I need a mouse I don't like
someone who calls himself after their
Mouse it's very I'm very intimidated
already the game hasn't even begun
[Music]
oh
um second The Exchange is interesting
I got 94 yeah whatever
before it takes takes Queen H6 King E8
no I did that King James
yeah and I'm losing I'm losing to New
York Mouse
whoa okay that's above my pay grade
like this
that was another terrible move
but I'm gonna of course the Queen's off
the board and then hopefully I can win
or not
to lose I'm blundering literally every
Pawn in the facility oh and I've learned
a piece too
which you didn't see
that would have ended the game
immediately
[Music]
I think I need to be committed to a
facility with the way I'm playing this
game oh man
this actually might be a draw though no
I'm just gonna find this but here
[Music]
no it's a draw
should be a draw
[Music]
six
stalemate
it's a nice save but unfortunately
breaks my streak
[Music]
but okay I can't I cannot win every
single game
[Music]
yeah first I should have won that out of
the opening but it's
[Music]
oh
okay obviously that that is that kind of
move is not something I can find in a
bullet game I'll leave that to the more
Advanced full of players Among Us
Bishop f8
she runs work B1
okay now that he let my thing goes over
his last chance
was to keep my king confined in a little
box
or not
um
I'm losing every single game that's not
that's the bad news good news is I'm
winning almost every single game
let's get bluebound
lubam is not a perk player so let's just
play Let's Play Theory
let's actually play Theory
get a good position and Win It
[Music]
it's gonna be hard to win though oh let
me play this move
I should just be able to stabilize
four at some point oh it gives me
another fun
okay nice
[Music]
okay now let's kill this guy
wow he knows his stuff I have to say he
really knows this stuff
it's all Theory up to E5 okay but he
can't really go B5 here that's white
Black's problem
okay plays it anyway
what
there's no way that works
no that's a terrible move
okay now please resign this is dead last
who is this guy
Abby oh it's Avi Kaplan okay I know who
that is
Abby Kaplan is without very talented
young player
yeah he's a dangerous young player from
New York
okay obviously I did not literally mean
let's kill this guy
oh I hate playing this guy I hate
playing him on Lee chess but this ain't
leeches is my territory
I always do this and then I get a
terrible position I lose okay let's go
F5
we got five get the Knight back and just
get a position
get all the pieces off the board with
him he's too strong in Middle games
oh man I already blundered
wait 95 okay 95 is a move though D4 I
have Knight G4 thankfully
simplify simplify
and I go C6 here
not very pleasant
it's not plus somebody has no way to
improve
no easy way to improve
foreign
he's just Flawless this guy I'm gonna
try to trick him
I have B5 though wait wait wait wait he
just made a mistake the moment I said
he's Flawless he blundered a queen
yes and I'm one tempo in time
unbelievable I literally said those
words and then either put he made the
worst move of the game he did everything
Tau claiming that end game and then lost
okay we're fine
all right
Jasper
okay so with gotta you literally need to
play for the clock that's all I need to
do is play for the freaking clock all
game long
you might have already won a piece
yes I have one a piece and confirm
fortunately this is still very messy
foreign
oh no wait I have this yes I have that
now I'm going to win
I actually disliked playing gotta very
much very very much because he's he
plays Incredible moves like you cannot
just play anything against him because
he will win
if flagging him sounds easy but it's not
trust me it's really not like you gotta
actually keep the tension
for most of the game
okay now now I'm gonna win but
because he doesn't pre-move
[Music]
okay we're playing Terry
they're giving me all the all the
opponents I hate playing
final trade
takes to excuse it should be good
okay
[Music]
thank you
Indian School of suffering
for The Armenian variation
foreign
this is me
hopefully I didn't blunder anything here
oh yes Queenie okay I did wonder that
let's see that he could take that pawn
I'm just gonna go into the ungiven
plugin
or at least that's the plan
he's good this guy's been playing very
well he's just very slow
man every one of his moves I've
predicted like I literally
everything I think he's gonna do he's
done
okay that including that which is not
very good for me
he's gonna go C5
no he's gonna resign
okay we're playing Jasmine
okay plays before pawns attack right I
should be able to get him here
foreign
attack me
getting beaten on the clock here
[Music]
oh crap what's that
oh
foreign
I'm getting I think I'm getting much
stuff preparing since Sasha board neck
is on top
[Music]
every round I'm getting is very
difficult but this is the way I like it
this is what makes blood bro it's not
fun when you just play play like people
who can beat easily
I'm playing I'm saying this this game
I'm playing terribly I'm gonna lose
unless I turn this around
okay when you get our pieces into the
center first of all
okay wait here I need to be very
accurate
Sergey somehow always plays very well in
bullet brawls
I need to find a tactic of some sort
okay here
oh wait I can take though it's not the
end of the world
I mean
he's just overwhelmingly like playing
way too way too strong in this game
yeah you can't really play passively
against him
it's not a good idea
that's me
he played a Flawless game
okay McCullough
[Music]
peace here
black is better here
yeah I've never seen Chicago I honestly
have never seen trigalko play this well
in my life that was insane
I'm not even upset to lose that game I
had no chance
why did I do that stupid move
okay F6
according resource
takes and knights obvious Knight p7
though
for that I'm not too scared of though
playing this very imprecisely
trying to get active here
okay but he can't move his King
[Music]
what am I doing I allowed
oh my gosh and I'm gonna somehow I found
the one way
stop this Pawn
I have to get his Pawn here
unbelievable to draw
okay I have to like try to
how to see what does he do though
oh yes Renegade Rook unbelievable
I mean just unlucky very unlucky
I found the one way not to win that
really this life
oh my gosh
okay long Castle
and I really struggle against McCullough
for whatever reason a bullet
I know we have a position it's not that
bad
the night begin
s
I need to get past Joss from the 60
seconds I don't think I can stop board
Nick at 84 but I can get second
[Music]
definitely gets okay resume is good but
not amazing
definitely not amazing
always they always freaking do that
always
did I blunder some Knight G6 garbage no
I didn't
he's calculating that too I'm sure
although I don't know why I would allow
all of his pieces to get on perfect
squares but
three
it takes a tick though
oh
okay nice
hold on hold on
oh now he's gonna go Bishop G5 and win
oh you can go to Joe anyway
okay it's double edged
it's Castle
I have to win this one I have to have to
have to win this one
this is a very big game
you can actually know I've got five
six
good knight G3 now no
I set up mate between H4 intending
rookie 6 and 823
she's six oh we can take a little bit
because people see so much
4-H where can I take it yes I can
good that was a huge win now let's win
another one in past Jasmine okay I got
Jocelyn that's the perfect pairing
actually
I like this bearing this gives me a
chance to stop his streak
okay but I'm not playing well
doing
foreign
yeah I had to take the try here I'm just
dead lost on the board
shoot okay but at least we stopped his
streak too so we reset okay fortnite
and can they give me a slightly easier
pairing please
[Music]
sort of threading mishbeth8
oh and I blow tonight
before he wants to Fork me on F6
get out of that hole business
[Music]
B6 very fortunately I have this move
foreign
[Music]
that was a great game I played very very
well that game
big big big big big win now we need to
win okay we get a 20. finally I get a
slightly easier pairing I feel like I've
gotten only only the top guys
yeah oh my God why am I like only
getting good players like why
the players like only coins
I'm a gods
so triggering
I'm a guides let's go 97.
foreign
maybe some music
something that won't interfere with my
Play-Doh I don't know what exactly
[Music]
see anything if I take here
Queen away
Queen shouldn't win
or not
oh shoot
oh okay wait now wait wait no Panic
no Panic come come come calculate takes
Bishop G3 okay two okay all good all
good all good
yeah but I played a lot of armik
recently
Place Another armik album
s ago
[Music]
this album takes me back
let me know if it's too loud or
something
okay big win okay Jasper's winning again
it's crazy
I do have to pass jobs from at some
point
[Music]
okay this guy ugh Pleasant opponent
does everyone know The Theory of
Everything
okay goodbye
[Music]
okay
bad
oh I had Knights okay I still have it
another win goodbye
next one
MSB
[Music]
I allowed this
that's okay it's a closed position
okay I need a some way to not lose here
okay let me pause for a sec sorry guys
I'm just I need to focus this game oh my
gosh now first thing I did was blunder
but he didn't so
have to like not lose
it here
[Music]
this is a bad move
only chances this is exposed to King
okay maybe check for sure I don't see
how he wins the fight
okay wait now I just have to be careful
to find the Propet
and he had a way to run away
he's not I mean can he get himself mated
here no
I mean it was a good it was a good hold
but
it was not enough to win
okay let's quickly try to beat Benjamin
very alert
[Music]
um here takes doesn't work which
basically doesn't work okay so go back
should be three before it doesn't work
so we what do we do we go back
forward page three time down
oh you can't go Knight c3o has no move
nice super strap one
and I'm still sucking behind Jasmine
okay New York Mouse again Abby Kaplan
he loves this garbage with H4
I hate playing against systems where
it's just it's easy to attack
but instincts young man
good instincts
I knew he was gonna go after me
Queen up for now 95 Maybe
and clean up form okay that's free Queen
adjustment just wins and wins and wins
oh we get Jasmine let's pause
oh C5 Bishop Porky thank God
um
foreign
is she's starting to attack
okay it's a good queen of two
be nasty
oh let's see what he was doing
oh my gosh and I blundered
and almost
oh leave it to nihal
leave it to nehal
there's some people I can never play in
tournaments and nehal is one of them
yeah I was I had a great position I had
a great position I was just
not precise enough I I should could have
could have easily stopped the storm on
the king side
just brainless of me
very rough pairing can you hold black
can you rebuild this streak now
he's gonna Castle quick okay now he's
gonna Force the contract also very bad
also very bad very bad
yeah I should have won that I was I was
up on time and I had a good position
what is this guy why is he playing so
well
why did I do that this is stupid
need to create a password on the inside
my best chance to play G5 here
you know but I'm also losing all my
Pawns
so goddamn accurate
and now he's pushing and he's winning
trying to generate counter play at all
costs here but no he's playing perfectly
need to flag him here
foreign
this is really rough
is this guy
oh my gosh
I'm gonna flag in my tank
um or not
yes I'm gonna flag him oh he smokes that
was tough
I think that might be lavage it was I
can't believe
I keep getting Larina
I need some more Red Bull
laughs
foreign
I need the chance to win fast
okay 52 minutes left there's almost half
the barrel remaining
okay board neck looks like he's running
away with it unfortunately and Jasmine
is now in a huge streak as well
so I have to win the next one stolen
Monster again
[Music]
he's gonna play the system
no that was stupid but okay
more or less got away with it
I'm wondering I managed to lose this
didn't I
[Music]
I did
lose this
there's nothing I can do but perfectly
as well
[Music]
I'm just so stupid it's a terrible game
foreign
I played very lazy I deserved to lose
[Music]
another Beast
small win
relatively quickly so not a disaster but
Jocelyn is winning all of his games it
appears yes Jasmine is going to win all
his other games
Lucy getting that he's been he's under
like okay he's getting very very easy
opponents so now I gotta win as well
foreign
yeah now he's in trouble those are
classic oh of course he's got this
[Music]
okay still equal
93 now
I don't want to keep the this is risky
but
it's very very I'm playing a very
dangerous game here
check check no
no
I have no idea how he was 27 something
much much much much much better than
that
this up well
foreign
Checkmate here
very very topsy-turvy game but I think
it's a job done
Garcia
and bullets he's not the same as he is
in Blitz
got to be losing
I just got to be losing
I grabbed that pawn but that allows our
page once let's just drop back
takes
can't find a move suddenly
to bring all my pieces into the game
here
the game
and blue balm
I really wonder who Jocelyn is getting I
really am really really curious
it's the pace at which he's winning is
absolutely off the charts
okay he had a very unpleasant move
Knight C4 there as you didn't see
that
[Music]
foreign
oh finally someone does that finally oh
my Are you seriously gonna play that
though is he seriously gonna play this
really okay I I hope he resigns yeah
yeah no he's not okay that that really
helps me because if he had taken a
minute off the clock there that would be
very annoying
I mean I was waiting for somebody to do
that I usually pre-move okay wait
my account okay good pairing
that's why I always pre-move Bishop
takes d8 in those situations because
someone always does that there's usually
one per tournament
is usually one per tournament
must went fast here
it's not a good idea but at least they
get some attacking chances
wow Knight G8 and a bullet game
seriously
girl
okay trying to like
get his clock
running
[Music]
oh no oh my gosh
does he see it though he does not he
does not
does not see now I'm in a sack now I'm
gonna sack for it I could have taken to
the other Rook also
could have taken it the other Rook but
now it's winning
four to set up some mating threats
not a smooth game at all but I'm gonna
get the job done
I need Jasmine to lose though it's very
important or I just need to beat his ass
[Music]
okay he did lose Jasper did lose so
let's try to win a couple here get that
streak rolling
okay this is a beatable opponent
yes we got him quickly
and we get Bortnick uh
[Music]
I need to beat him here
Maybe
[Music]
thank you
I don't like the mirberg T3 but I think
I'll have to do
[Music]
so I've got a solid situation here going
because I'm defending the pawn
foreign
let's just go here and take this guy
I'll be able to win pretty
straightforwardly
unless I blunder my Knights
why am I struggling here
okay
there we go
okay I broke a streak unfortunately for
Sasha I don't want to beat him I mean I
want him to win the tournament but I
also got to keep my own streak up
that's a mistake
thank you
[Music]
Jasper's on a streak again
and who would have who would have
doubted that right
[Music]
clearly I'm gonna win this game but
do it fast and efficiently
or maybe I'm not going to win this game
the way I'm playing
[Music]
It's Gonna Take and try to flag him
yeah but the time disparity is too much
buffer let's try to go for a quick
knockout here yeah
fortunately he's got Rook takes
not clean but he resigns instead that's
a big gift ah I blue bum again
always does this and he's always winning
oh why did I I could have played A5 so
many times
could have played okay I'm just busted
here it's basically no use to play this
but I'm gonna try
I am gonna try
okay I got us night back at least
thank you
[Music]
only he blundered from science to time
which he never seems to do
but that's definitely bad
oh
I didn't see that
drunk
not bad I mean that's a good result
obviously
really
Corrales
[Music]
I was probably even winning at the end
but
I need to win this one of course
foreign
let's go for it oh it took that's the
wrong move order
I'm playing so passively
pieces out damn come on
panic panic panic panic
keeps finding these weird moves and what
to do against them
I need to open my position up a little
bit just to make it easier to play
okay that should be losing though given
the clock situation
Fidel is fast but he's not that best
unless I get unlucky and put my Rook on
free
[Music]
man Jasper just doesn't ah move on again
I'm gonna mix it up a little bit
ghost let's go for the pawn here
whoops that helps okay okay
that helps a lot but Jasper won again
yeah I mean Justin's catching up to me
even though I'm not losing any games
bubbles are Nikki that's a that's a
blast from the past
it's a blast from the past they used to
be pretty good on on ICC
no not to be trifled with clearly
he's trading all the pieces which I
don't like
this is the game okay resign please
and oh we're getting Elsa that's not
good
it was freaking little it's not it's not
because Sparrow it's Leon freaking
levage why can't I beat this guy
it's not that good
[Music]
H6 is oh my gosh what fix I guess
now I don't understand this guy
trying to get this complicated
open open stuff up open up the center
here and open everything oh
is Leon this good
let's try my best here thank you Michiko
for the 20. see those subs thank you
very much
and pre-move safely looks like I'm
turning the game around here on the
clock and on the board
but it's freaking Elsa so he can never
relax against Elsa
and a girl in my high school named Elsa
oh man huge win Thomas the five Subs as
well thank you very much
okay big big big big big big big big big
big win
you know I can't take there
[Music]
look like my position here though not
one bit
[Music]
not one bit
nine
make that that'll help
let's thank you
thank you michrico thank you Thomas
appreciate it sorry I'm just focused on
the game so I'm not thanking you with
sufficient gusto
he's missing a lot of chance you're not
a man with five subs thank you
getting a lot of wholesomeness here from
the community thank you very much I
appreciate it
okay when that one relatively quickly
Jasper oh it's Harry gotta win this one
I win this one
[Music]
I go like this
I get very tactical against him
laughs
[Music]
foreign
you know always seems to play very well
space for the Knight here
[Music]
trying to not just trying to not get
checkmated here that's the only goal
[Music]
I think Arena bidicaro a couple times
ago
[Music]
you know why I'm playing so nervous here
I am winning the world
[Music]
all right
okay now I have a chance to catch sash
this is this is pretty brutal I have to
say
oh I lagged
uh-oh
I'm lagging a little bit here okay now
it sounds seems too fine
blender
[Music]
as was that
no one knows pawns here
all right
zero P6 Maybe
foreign
[Music]
actually winning on the board
of course
[Music]
foreign
here
okay Bortnick I I do want Sasha to win
this one deserves it
I don't know if I can take the fun there
because I'm trying to knock out Jasmine
foreign
a huge streak too so he he totally
deserves this one
but second place would be very nice 56.
I feel like
practically this is a good move because
of all the threats on the king said I
can post
I don't know what I'm doing right now
but
I'm pretending to attack
what am I doing I'm starting to play
very sloppy let's focus and deliver a
couple good moves here
she three knocks the Knight away
three Pawn there we go now we got him
or not
Abby's got too many threats he has to
deal with here
gonna get Terry again
gotta beat him here
he always goes into this line it's not a
very good line
uh
can I go F5 probably not gonna go
foreign
I had a five I still have a five I
missed it
what happened whoa
oh girl 20 Subs wait did I win that game
I did win that game
it's away
[Music]
not sure this game I'm playing very very
poorly but
where's the mail where's no mate since
there's no mate let's just go back
[Music]
okay Carl kind of lover
bumper
[Music]
I don't like the way I'm playing the
last couple games
[Music]
oh I should be able to win
foreign
[Music]
thank you
as of that
mechanic
[Music]
keep that time advantage on this guy
thank you
[Music]
oh crap
this is everything
[Music]
thank you
John that's a good player
foreign
[Music]
does work well okay in that case
oh all of it works let's see
[Music]
no no I'm Bishop D5 no
okay I have to use my Pawn here
should be a dry should not be losing
this one
I think
although
no I am losing
wait
ah
I'm threatening rugby G1 which is a dry
thing I think it's a draw actually you
need to be careful you might lose this
is I'm gonna start running this way
oh my gosh motherfudge
[Music]
um here
ah 50 more bro nothing I could do that
time
we're in a marina
I mean I did everything within my power
to win that game but he just he was just
too freaking fast
no way he's 2700 that's ridiculous
okay quickly rebuild this streak in the
last 13 minutes Jasper also is out of
the streak so
pretty decent shape here
[Music]
but I need to win a couple games very
quickly here just to make sure Jasmine
doesn't matter last second run
[Music]
ah make a move Daniel come on
I'm too slow
this game
congrats to Sasha
and um that's about it I'm gonna end for
now
Ronald got fifth yeah I'm surprised
nehal didn't do better than he than he
did nihal where was nihal
surprisingly nihal only got 24 out of 29
okay so he didn't play the whole bullet
brawl
he won almost all his games but
When You Haul us to some weak players
I'm very
surprised because nehal's bullet is is
absolutely unbelievable
yeah there's a real good shot or some of
these 2500s are very very dangerous very
dangerous
um I might be back later tonight we'll
see I'm
pretty tired and I've got a lot to take
care of but
um but I'll do my best
all right guys
thank you everybody
congrats Sasha very happy for him and um
very happy for him and we are gonna raid
I would assume that Bortnick is done
so I'm gonna raid
let's read botes let's read both says
yeah I've gotten some raids from Ali
from Alexandra let's read bothas
and thank you guys for the support
couldn't have done it without you
sending you over to vote says thanks for
hanging out and um
hopefully I'll see you later tonight or
if not tonight then definitely tomorrow
bye
[Music]